All right, welcome everybody, another stream,
it's been a while, playing League and answering questions,
and I'm with my co-host, as usual, RishyCup.
Rishy, welcome aboard.
Thank you, Evan, thanks for having me.
How long has this been?
Oh, too long.
This was, I think, back in May, his last stream.
Wow, it took me a while to figure out
how to get everything set up again,
but we're here, I'm queuing up.
Jungle first, mid-second,
and we're gonna answer questions.
So, Rishy, before getting into it,
you wanna tell everybody a little bit about
what you do in your channel,
for people who may not be familiar?
Absolutely, and while I'm doing that,
I don't see you live,
but you're definitely live.
Okay.
It says I'm live.
So, yeah, I'm gonna search you again.
So, I am Rishy from RishyKopp TV,
and those of you who are part of Belize Nation,
shout out to Belize Nation, love you guys.
And yeah, so I have a channel where good music,
good food, and good talk intersect,
although I will be making an announcement soon
with a little bit of some changes.
It might not be good music, good food, good talk anymore,
but I will let you guys know.
And yeah, I'm just having a really good time making videos
and trying to grow always with making great content
for my audience.
Very cool.
And you've been very helpful to me, Evan,
all through the process, so thank you so much.
I love it, I love it.
Well, I just confirmed that we are live, so this is good.
Just to make sure.
I think you may just have to refresh the page.
Oh, maybe that's what it is.
That's what it did for me.
It doesn't just tell you that it's live.
Cool, so what we're doing here,
for those of you who are new,
is we answer questions that people ask me via email
and a couple other places, I guess,
while I play League of Legends.
And so, I'm not that great a player,
but learning to get better and multitask.
So, Rishy is gonna be queuing up the questions,
sharing her wisdom as well,
and hopefully we help some entrepreneurs today.
So, let's kick it off.
Rishy, what's the first question?
Okay, we've got a designer from India named Tealu,
and she says, Evan, I'm writing this to you
because in spite of being talented
and knowing the techniques of my business,
again, this is fashion business,
for the last 15 years, I'm still struggling to make even.
I'm forever stuck, for whatever reason.
I just can't achieve my dream of becoming rich.
My dream is to fly high in my business,
be recognized globally.
I know my profession well,
but have no entrepreneurial skills.
So, she needs your help.
How can I take this to the next level
so I don't have to struggle
month to month with my staff, Valerie?
And she actually has a staff of 12 people,
so she's got a, you know, she's doing something right.
She's got a staff of 12 people,
but she needs your help to get her to the next level.
And she's a fashion designer, is that what it was?
Yep, she's a fashion designer.
Okay, so what do you think?
So, you want me to go first?
Yeah.
Well, you know, this is interesting because,
again, it sounds like she's doing a lot of things right.
She's been in business for 15 years,
has a staff of 12 people,
but seems like she's stuck at this level
and she can't break through.
So, two things come to mind.
I'm wondering what she would discover
if she were to start thinking about
some of her limiting beliefs,
because I've heard you talk a lot about
some of the biggest breakthroughs you've received
in your business from getting from one level to the next
was with discovering some of your limiting beliefs.
But another thing that comes to mind as well is that,
you know, I'd like to hear what you'd have to say
maybe in a future video about how to,
because it sounds like some of her issues
are just finances and going from a place of check to check
to a place of actually wealth and having more than enough.
And I think a lot of us as entrepreneurs
come into this with such different levels
of money management background
and we come from different backgrounds
and we live in different countries
and have different families.
So I wonder too, if there might be some value
in her examining, you know, how does she think about money?
How is she spending money?
How is she saving money?
And like, how can she get to a different and even place
where she's not just living just to check?
That's my input.
Yeah, I would love to see her go after bigger clients
and bigger deals.
I think it's easy to, as you're starting up,
to just put everything back into the business
and just continue to struggle.
But if you have 12 employees,
then you're making some money.
I don't know how much money she's making.
She didn't share that, but she's making some money.
And if you're investing it all back into the staff,
like if you are not taking anything home
and you're barely able to survive,
then you're investing into your growth
or your business model is broken, right?
Then it's either like you're investing so much
into your growth that you're consciously
still bootstrapping it yourself
because you want to be able to build something amazing
or your business model sucks
in that you're not making enough money.
Like if these people are just what you need
to complete the projects,
then you need to start getting paid more.
It sounds like it's not invested back into the growth.
It sounds like she wants to take some money off the table
and be able to do a little bit more than survive.
And so it feels like, oh, somebody just took my team out.
Unbelievable.
Oh, I'm so upset.
I'm so upset that I'm going to have to think.
Okay, we're going to go, we're going to go Quinn.
Oh.
You're going to get your money.
Of course, on my game here, I got to, okay, anyway.
That's frustrating.
Yeah, so I just feel the business model needs to be improved
where you need to start charging more
or go after bigger clients who can,
who couldn't afford it.
Like you may be providing the insane value,
just the people who you're selling to right now
don't appreciate that value.
You know, they like your art, but they don't love your art.
You know, if I look at the deals that I made,
the brands that I've worked with,
as I've gotten bigger and gotten more followers
and gotten more attraction and freedom of product or value,
some of the people that I work with or used to work with,
you know, really loved everything I could give them,
but didn't fully appreciate the value,
didn't have the budget to be able to work with me as I grew.
And so you need to work with clients
who appreciate your value and can afford your value
and then be able to factor into your business model
that you're going to take a little bit extra home
and not just always invest it back into the staff.
That's great.
I see that the Twitch chat,
you're monitoring the Twitch chat there, ARishy, right?
Yes, I am.
Shout out to Stefan and Zano.
What's up, guys?
This is going to go a lot,
this is going to go on the YouTube channel after,
but we do live on Twitch,
slowly building up that audience too.
Okay, we got a question in.
I'm playing Queen Jungle, not super happy about it,
but it's okay, my first game back in, let's do it.
All right, you ready?
Let's do it, what's our next question?
Okay, from Hiram Miranda.
Now Hiram has a car blog and a digital magazine.
He's been doing this blog since 2012.
He has a few fans and a few blog post views.
He's also really passionate about men's style
and motivation and he wants to create a new blog
where he can combine these two topics.
His question is, would you recommend starting this project
at the same time while he's still working on his car blog?
He feels like he can't give too much value
talking about cars and he really wants
to get out of his job.
So this is something that he really wants to,
you know, be successful and monetize.
And my, okay, so that was his question from Hiram.
I absolutely think for sure he should start this next blog
while he's doing the car blog.
It's always a good thing to kind of test drive, right?
And see if you can find the place
where you're really providing value for people
and why not start them and do them both at the same time
and see what kind of comes from that.
And yeah, that's pretty straightforward.
What do you think Evan?
I would start with understanding motivation behind it.
Is the drive to move into lifestyle
and what was the other one, health?
Lifestyle, what was the other one?
Like cars.
Motivation, it's men's style.
So men's style and motivation,
like is the interest there because you actually love it
or you just hate your job
and you're trying to monetize somehow, right?
Like he's had a successful or he's had a car blog
that hasn't been massive successful,
it hasn't allowed him to quit his job.
And so is it, I'm going to get into this other thing
because I'm trying to make money
and I'm just trying to quit my job
or is it something that you're actually passionate about?
Because if you're not, it was just like,
if you think it's easier to make money in there
than it is in cars, then it's not going to work.
It's just going to be a big waste of time.
On the other hand though, if he really loves it,
like if he loves style and he loves motivation
and he loves cars, then I would try to combine them.
I wouldn't continue with the car blog.
I would try to mix them together
for the kind of ultimate men's blog
that I can go to for all of that stuff together.
I think when you try to divert your attentions too much,
it just becomes, like I look at my channel,
if I had to have a channel for every series that I have,
it'd be insane to keep up with logging into each account
and keeping track of the comments and uploading the videos
and it's just, it's too complicated.
Simple is better when you're getting started,
but also it allows things to build
where if you have a really successful car blog
that's getting some traction and tension
or post that just takes off and does really well,
then the next time you post something else,
it automatically does better.
Like if you post a blog about motivation,
you're not starting from scratch each time with motivation.
Right.
So I always prefer what I call combining
the genius to the end, bring things together.
But I would still just be conscious of at the start,
making sure it's something
that you deeply have a passion for
and it's not just something you're trying to make money at
because you hate your job.
And maybe one little extra tangent on there,
if you hate your job, I'd be looking for a job
where you can learn to make this business better.
If this is your end goal,
that you want this thing to take off
and you want to be a full-time blogger,
then go work at a digital company
where you can learn some of the skills
to be a great blogger.
There you go.
That's great.
Like don't stick with a job you hate,
go to a job where you're actually going to do something.
Good answer.
Did that guy just say good answer?
He's a guy in the background.
I swear he just said good answer.
I know he's not talking about us,
but I feel it.
I'm feeling the love.
Evan, for those of us
who don't play League of Legends every day,
are you the guy in the purple shadow?
Purple shadow.
I don't know.
I'm the guy that you see walking around on screen.
Yeah, it's got like a nice little purple hue around your...
Oh, that's because I killed one of the frog guys
and I got poisoned.
Oh.
So it's poisoning characters.
Yeah, I'm the guy doing the poison.
This is a bit of a trickier champ.
I'm not used to him as much.
Him, her?
No, Quinn is a woman.
So I started this series,
one, to give me some time to get better,
but also to purposely divert,
like to purposely practice being able to answer questions
while I'm distracted.
Okay.
To see, just like to stretch my brain,
as an exercise.
But it's harder when I'm not as familiar with the champion.
But so far, so good.
I'm just walking around the jungle,
not getting any fights yet.
And we'll see.
Cool, okay.
Thank you for the card block question.
What do we have next?
All right, we've got a question from Asigway Damien.
All right.
And Asigway, he says, he starts his question saying,
business capital problem, feel like a dead man.
Wow.
Capital problems, is that what he said?
Yeah, business capital.
Okay.
And he says, he's in General Electronics.
He's a General Electronics wholesaler.
And he lost capital through his container last year.
And he says, he really needs help negotiating.
And he's looking for a sponsor.
He wants to know, can you push his request to Oprah?
All right.
Let me get on the phone with Oprah.
She's playing a game with me right now.
So what is he selling, wholesale electronics?
Wholesale electronics.
Okay.
And he basically has a capital problem.
There is no more detail than that.
It's clear that he is really needing the capital quick.
And so I guess my first tip to Asigway,
only because he didn't put much more information,
is first of all, just sorry that you lost
all this money in a container.
Have you heard about this containers, Evan?
If I'm understanding you correctly,
those are like, I have a friend who is in Africa
and you get all your stuff in these big containers.
And sometimes in places there can be a lot of robberies
and people steal the stuff in your container.
Any who, sorry that that happened.
That's pretty devastating.
I would just say that usually capital problems are,
what I've learned from you, Evan,
is that when you are talking about capital problems,
you're talking about also a value.
Like if you need more capital,
you have to start thinking about your value,
what value are you providing?
And so if you really can provide great value,
you will start to see that change in capital.
And he talks about asking for help from Oprah
or some kind of sponsorship.
And another thing that I hear you talk a lot about
is just in general,
don't go into looking for investors right away.
Like you got to bootstrap it in the beginning
and really just, well, in this case,
it looks like it's, I don't even know if it's his business
or someone else's business, but he's in general electronics.
So yeah, I don't think that would be the way to go
necessarily looking for some celebrity
to give you the money to do what it is that you wanna do.
I would just say, dig deeper into providing more value
and differentiating your business
from other general electronics in some way.
And so sorry, I hope that you can get to the next level.
Yeah, definitely sad.
I would start with not having so much
of your personal value tied up in your business.
You feel like you're dead because your business,
something negative happened in your business.
There's a lot more to life than just the company doing.
And I get that it's super important.
Your life is super, your business is super important.
I would be sad if my YouTube channel disappeared
or whatever I was working on,
my book manuscript blew up or whatever.
But not to the point where I'm giving up on life.
And it may just mean also kind of,
oh, this guy's stealing my red or my blue.
Ah, unbelievable that guy.
It may be trying to figure out what value you can add
and being grateful for your life beyond just your business
and not having everything so tied up in it.
That being said, the most immediate thing I would look at
is how can you get insurance for what you're doing?
It sounds like a classic insurance case
where something gets stolen, something gets lost.
To prevent something happening again,
look at some insurance products that don't know,
there's gotta be some that exist
for what you're trying to do.
That doesn't help with the immediate solution,
but it helps with things in the future
to prevent that from happening again.
Nobody's coming to save you, right?
This is tough love time.
Nobody's coming to save you.
Bad stuff happens and you gotta figure it out.
Oprah is not gonna write you a check to save your business.
You have to save you.
And you have to take responsibility
for where you're at right now.
And yeah, bad stuff happens.
Things burn down, stuff gets stolen.
You get back up and you keep going.
That's the life of an entrepreneur, unfortunately.
It's not about your resources,
it's about your resourcefulness.
And seeing Oprah do something amazing to help people out
and think that that's my,
if that's your plan to save your business
that Oprah has to come in and give you a check,
you are gonna be struggling for a long time.
Wow, it's real.
Yeah, it's real.
But Oprah doesn't care about your shipping business.
Nobody's gonna care about your shipping business
as much as you do.
So you have to go out and save your business yourself.
And just in general, I get a lot of people saying,
hey, can you, I'm really struggling,
can you give me $500 or $10,000 or $100,000
or whatever it is.
Like that's not how it's gonna work for anybody.
And most people, you send something to Oprah,
she's just gonna ignore you.
Right, I'm, this may be harsh,
but at least it's the real talk.
I'd like to think that she wouldn't ignore me
if I sent her a letter.
Yeah, but she will.
Like, you know, look at how many people send Oprah stuff.
Right?
It's just.
At least you don't ignore her.
She can't keep up, right?
Like a plan like that. You're right, you're right.
It's just, so it's on you.
And then back to your point, like, no, okay,
tactical, how do you actually get out of this?
It's to your point about adding more value
from before, right?
What can you do to bring value
so that you're not just another wholesaler
of electronics equipment,
but there's something special, unique,
and different about you so that you can make more money.
And you just gotta get through this period.
Like, I don't see an investor coming in
and giving you money to save your business right now.
Yeah, yeah.
And that sucks, and that may mean bootstrapping, right?
If I lost all my money, and I lost my YouTube channel,
and I lost everything that I was doing,
I would start up on YouTube again.
And I would do it all myself.
And I'd go back to one video a week.
And that would be a huge ego pill to swallow.
And that's really the test of like,
do you love what you're doing?
Now you're providing some real value, right?
I would go back to doing one video a week,
doing everything myself, and that's it.
So you might have to scale back a little bit.
Oh, people are upset that they have no jungle.
Yeah, sorry guys, I'm not really paying attention.
I'm trying to answer questions.
I'm being a bad teammate at the moment.
But hopefully helping some listeners.
I don't think you could ever go back to one video a week.
Well, I'm saying like, if I lost everything, right?
This guy had some really bad luck, right?
Something happened, he lost his container.
Maybe he put his life savings into that container, right?
So the equivalent, if I lost everything I had,
I lost my channel and lost my team
and couldn't afford to pay anybody or whatever,
I would start up again, just smaller,
and then build back up.
So that's what he has to do.
Just do it smarter.
Don't count on somebody coming to save you.
Take out insurance next time so that you're not screwed over
if something does happen.
And to make more money, provide more value
in what you're selling to differentiate yourself
so it's not just another guy selling the same stuff.
That's it.
Great.
You ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Hopefully the next one, I mean,
I feel like it's maybe a little bit tough love there,
but it's true.
So let's see, let's see how it goes with the next one.
Let's turn it around.
Okay, we got a question from Adam,
and he says he had gotten below average SAT scores
and rejected from every college he applied to.
Then he started his first real semester
at a community college.
He was super driven and motivated in all his classes
and then finally got accepted.
So he did so well in the community college
that he then got accepted and was able to transfer
to the university of his dreams.
And anyway, to his surprise,
he got to the new university of his dreams
and now he doesn't feel driven
and he's not as excited about his classes
like he was in the community college
and he feels really isolated.
So he's starting to wonder why he's there at all
and he's asking just for general advice.
So I guess I would say first and foremost,
what comes to mind is, you know,
I always lose my motivation and my drive
when I lose my why and when I lose my vision.
And so we can all relate.
I know we can all relate to times
when like we are way more driven than others.
And I don't necessarily think it means
that the school that he's at now isn't the right place
because I think if you have a really good strong why
and vision for what it is that you wanna do,
then you find the motivation kind of wherever you are.
But it sounds obviously like his why is unclear.
My question to you, Adam, would be,
can you figure out what it was about the,
what was different in the community college?
What was really clear to you about what you were doing there
that gave you motivation and inspiration
to be really driven?
Because I think if he can figure that out,
he can bring that to the new university.
Yeah, that's all I got.
All right, we just got a kill, so super happy about that.
Pretty exciting.
Adam, right?
Yes, Adam.
Adam, I think it's okay to realize that you change
and what you think you like, sometimes you don't like.
You get into a relationship with a girl
and you think it's gonna be great
and then once you start in, it's not great.
You start a business and it's not working
or you start a business and you realize
you don't love this thing anymore.
And what most people do is stick with it.
What most people do is they stay in the same job
because maybe they were good at it
or because their parents wanted them to do it or whatever
and they just wake up and drive to a job
that they hate every day.
Where the best thing to do is explore
until you find the thing that makes you come alive
and do that until it doesn't make you come alive anymore.
You have genius level talent at something
and you have to find what that is.
And that comes by exploring.
And if you keep doing things,
if you stay here doing something that you don't love,
you're never gonna be the best version of you.
So that may mean switching majors.
Maybe you wanna go try something else
but staying within your university.
That may mean dropping out and going to do something else.
You look at Steve Jobs as an example
and he dropped out of his school
where everybody thought he was crazy.
To go back to school as a volunteer,
like not get credit,
to learn about fonts and calligraphy
and that helped him create.
When the Mac came out, it had the best fonts.
And that only happened because he dropped in on that class
where it didn't make any sense at that time,
likely even to him.
He didn't know why he was doing it.
It's just something that was interesting to him.
You can be the best in the world at something
but it's only gonna come
when you are enjoying what you're doing.
This doesn't mean every day you enjoy it.
Everybody's gonna have down days
but on the whole, you enjoy it.
I look at my YouTube channel, I enjoy doing it.
Some things, if I don't enjoy it, I'll stop.
Like if we're testing this series out,
me playing League, playing games,
if it's not enjoyable for me, I'm gonna stop.
If they keep banning my Teemo, holy cow.
I'm gonna stop.
But all jokes aside, if I didn't like YouTube anymore,
I wouldn't do it just because it's making me money.
That's not the reason to do it
because I'll never be a great YouTuber.
The people who are at the top in any field
actually love what they're doing
and it's not just something that they're trying
to make a bunch of cash off of.
So there's probably a lot of smart, safe, logical,
practical reasons for you to stay there
and keep on and do this career.
But really, I think you need to switch
to do something else that makes you come alive.
Yeah, he didn't actually clarify what he's pursuing there.
I would be curious to know what that was.
Because you're right, maybe he's just in the wrong major.
Maybe he hasn't declared a major yet,
but maybe he's just in the wrong, you know.
Yeah.
All right.
I probably got another kill there, so I'm pretty happy.
Although they're calling me useless in my team chat.
They're calling me useless.
Oh, that's bad.
I know, it's pretty harsh, right?
It's true, though, right?
This is a ranked game.
I'm supposed to be paying attention.
But I am 2-0.
I am 2-0, so I got two kills and no deaths,
so it's not that bad.
We got Jay saying you'll probably need Maa and or Murk,
Murceril or Murkural to stop alkaline.
I don't know what that means, but there you go.
Thanks, Jay.
Okay, keep going, what do we got, what do we got?
Next person, I'm gonna call this person P.
P?
P, yep.
All right, P.
P is, no, that's like the word.
I'm saying that because his first name starts with P,
but I didn't.
Let's call him, let's call him John.
John.
John is 16 years old.
And ever since, let's see, since I've been 10,
he wanted to be a successful entrepreneur.
But he does not have very social skills.
And he lacks confidence.
When he tries to speak to strangers or girls,
he may have, it's just a doctor state, he has ADHD.
Basically, he just struggles with motivation,
or sorry, he struggles with innovation.
And he says, my lack of innovation kills me.
I look up to these great entrepreneurs,
but I simply cannot develop ideas in my mind for business.
I literally feel like spiritual suicide
when I wake up in the morning.
Yeah, when I wake up in the morning with no business,
no idea, nothing to work for and represent.
I feel like if I had a business idea,
this would motivate me and break this thing off of him
that's the social and intelligent thing.
Wow.
All right.
All right, what you got, Rishy?
Well, first of all, John,
I know you mentioned your age.
And I can just say that when I was 16,
no, I think when I was 17, probably 16, 17,
I went through some really, just depression
and feeling really empty.
And just a lot of things happened around that age for me.
And I think it's probably not uncommon for other teenagers,
adolescent, at that age that you start really,
you can, not everybody,
but you can go through a lot of stuff.
And it's clear that you are feeling like
this is kind of like a life or death situation.
And I just wanna say that you are being way harder
on yourself than you need to be.
And I appreciate the fact that you want to be
an entrepreneur, but also again,
thinking about how much time you have to develop your idea
and to, I'm thinking even about your situation now
with like some of the emotional stuff
that you're going through,
you said the intelligence, ADHD.
I mean, these are all things that feel
like they're like hindrances,
but I can pretty much guarantee that if you hang in there
and you try to grow as much as you can,
all of these things that feel like they are liabilities,
things that are hindering you
can actually be your greatest asset
because you're gonna be someone who probably really
can be sensitive to other people who struggle.
Anyway, so I just wanna say to you, you are not hindered.
You are actually uniquely,
kind of like what Evan told Adam in the last question.
You are, you have an intelligence.
What did you say, Evan, a genius?
That no one else has.
Yeah.
I don't know how you said it, but it was like so good.
Even with whatever hindrances you think you,
even with whatever hindrances you think you have,
there is something that you have that no one else has
that is a genius above every other person
that will make your business that much more powerful.
And I would just say, don't be so hard on yourself.
Gratitude is another thing Evan talked about,
learning to be grateful for where you are.
And I know that's not easy,
but I am pretty sure that you can get through this.
And patience is gonna be another huge thing
in the midst of this.
It's just, if the idea isn't there,
you can't force an idea, you know?
What do you think, Evan?
A couple of things.
One, again, tying so much value to the idea
of having a business that if you don't have the business,
then now you're depressed, right?
The business is not everything.
The business doesn't, just because you don't have a company
yet that makes you an unsuccessful, unlovable human being
is crazy and it's not true.
So just being conscious of that.
I got another kill.
Love it.
But I'm gonna die.
Okay, good.
Fly, fly, fly, fly, fly.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
They're gonna chase me, I'm gonna die.
Okay, good.
Okay, next.
Understand that you don't need to be a type A personality
outgoing to have a business.
We see them, you know, the people who are outgoing
are the ones that we see on TV and the one, you know,
getting all the media and the press and that's great.
They get that because they're leveraging
what they're good at, right?
They're leveraging their skills as somebody
who is really outgoing to win.
But there's a lot of entrepreneurs
who are not outgoing and still win.
Even sometimes in public arenas.
We just did a video on Ellen.
Oh yeah.
And she says she's not outgoing.
And she had to struggle with that and deal with that.
And here she is as someone who you think
is like a super outgoing person and comedian
in the public eye, but she's an introvert.
And I would recommend checking off that video
because it can help you.
But there's no one path.
Like the most common things that entrepreneurs,
that unites entrepreneurs is that they had a vision,
you know, and they got started on something.
And they took action every day.
The personality traits of, you know,
being outgoing or not or whatever else you think matters.
Like the money that you start with doesn't matter.
The education doesn't matter.
You know, where your parents come from doesn't matter.
You know, your sex, your race, you know, doesn't matter.
None of that matters.
And people continue to hold themselves back
because they tell themselves a story
that they think it matters, but it doesn't.
In terms of then coming up with an idea,
the easiest way to start is to look at your own life
and look at what you need, what you're frustrated by,
what you would love some help with.
Again, I share the story about the YouTube channel
and the things that do best on my YouTube channel,
I created out of my own desire, my own necessity.
The top 10 series is because I wanted that.
I wanted to learn from these famous entrepreneurs
and what they had done.
And I needed a little more, you know,
motivation in what I was doing.
I needed people to push me to do something bigger and better
and everybody likes it, you know, for the most part.
So I would be looking at my own life and seeing,
what do I need help with?
Like, what do I wish existed?
What frustrations do I have in any area?
You know, in something, look at gaming,
where people say, how can you make money playing gaming?
How can you provide value playing gaming?
There are people making insane money with gaming,
but they're providing value,
either by teaching people how to do it
or by being a professional gamer
or by entertaining people with their commentary.
There's a lot of different ways
to be able to have success.
So those three things, if I can remember, what did I say?
One, don't talk so much of your value as a human being,
your worth to having a business idea.
Two, you don't need to be outgoing
and extroverted to have success.
And then three, look at areas in your life
that you're unhappy with, that you're frustrated by,
and go solve that.
And chances are there's a lot of people
who also have the same problem
and they benefit from learning from how you handle it
and would be willing to pay you for it.
Yeah, I remembered it all.
All right, good.
Can I just add something to that though, Evan?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
You don't realize this, Mimi,
but just what you said there,
you said, I really wanted to be mentored
and pushed by people that were doing these great things.
So I just started this series.
That in and of itself is innovation
because a lot of people would go, I wanna be mentored.
I'll never get to meet Oprah.
I'll never get to meet Tony Robbins.
I'll never get to meet whoever.
So I guess it's just not,
I mean, just the way that you thought about that
is innovative and I mean, your channel is innovative.
So is there any insights you can give
on how to tap into innovation?
Is that the advice that you just gave
just in terms of like work out of a place
of your own frustration or your own what you need?
I mean, is that how innovations are born
is just by solving your own, you know,
scratching your own itch?
Because you seem to tap into innovation
in a way that's very powerful.
So what do you, I don't know,
how do you even know how you do that?
Yeah, yeah, okay, and it may look like
some like magic formula from the outside,
but really it's just finding a small way to get started.
Right, like I want to learn from Elon Musk,
like as an example, right?
I want to learn from Elon Musk.
You know, what's the easiest way
I can get started on that?
It's to watch his videos or read his books
or whatever else you can come up with.
It's not to try to call him up
and have him invest in my business plan
and hope that he says yes and you know,
how long does that take and if he doesn't say yes,
my life is over, right?
It's like finding an easy way to get started
and just trying to find solutions.
That's what entrepreneurship is all about.
When we were starting this series,
right when I wrote to you and said,
hey, I want to start this series,
do you want to join me on it?
We had to figure out some technical issues, right?
How are we going to stream it?
Where are you going to be?
How do we deal with phone, internet?
Are you going to be watching the stream or not?
Commenting, how do we get the questions?
All of these things, there's tons of problems that come up
and it's just finding a solution.
So whatever big thing that you want to do,
or maybe this is the lesson, maybe this is the disconnect,
you know, whatever the big thing is
that you want to get done,
just find a smaller way to start.
Break it down and find the smallest possible step
that you can start with.
And do it.
Like, you need to take action.
Like, just sit in there and thinking about it
and wishing for it, it's not going to happen.
You've got to do something.
Even if the something may not make sense,
or it doesn't work, you're doing something.
Oh, come on, that guy totally stole my kill.
Hi, Virginia.
Why does my team want to surrender?
We're winning.
Anyway.
So, yeah.
And people may not be able to see it.
I think people either don't see what a small step is,
they either don't see it at all,
or they think it's too small and won't work.
Yeah, yeah, I think it's cool to hear
you kind of just speak about it on a practical level
because I think it's like a mystery for some people
and just to see that you had this idea,
League of Legends, all right, let's just do it.
Let's just try it.
And, you know, if it doesn't work like you said,
go on to the next idea, try it again.
Yeah, I mean, look at this series right here.
You know, I have a popular YouTube channel.
I'm moving over to Twitch's live stream.
We've got 10 followers, 10 followers.
It's not a lot, right?
I've got 10 people who are following my channel,
subscribing, thank you guys, love you guys,
those 10 followers if you're watching live.
And I could pour a ton of resources if I wanted to into it.
I could promote it across my newsletter
and I could pump it out on YouTube,
and say follow me on Twitch live, but it's a test.
And people, if they don't get immediate success,
they get upset.
It's like Kali, oh, I died.
If they don't get immediate success,
they get frustrated and they quit.
Where it's in those small wins
that you develop something amazing.
I don't get immediately a thousand subscribers
on my YouTube channel, so I'm a failure.
So, just find the smallest way to get started.
Break it down, find the smallest way to get started,
and then do another step, and do another step,
and do another step.
That's awesome.
Are you dead?
I'm here.
No, yeah, I died, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I died.
I've had my first death.
I have four kills, six assists, and one death,
so it's not bad.
Akali killed me.
That's J-Ryze's champ of choice, usually.
Oh my gosh, is J playing right now?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't think so.
If he's watching the stream, he's not.
You said he left the stream there, right?
Oh, okay, okay, yeah.
Yeah, so if he's watching the stream, he's not playing.
He's not in the stream with me, although we have done that.
Boom, that guy's gone.
Okay, next, what do we got, what do we got?
Let's do it.
Good stuff.
All right, next question comes from Corinne.
She's a single mother, five kids,
and she has no formal qualifications,
but a desire to be successful.
She feels torn because when she's pursuing her goals,
it's usually at the expense of her children.
So she currently scaled back her activities drastically
since her dance studio was closed last year,
and now she feels like a failure,
and her confidence is shattered once again.
I'm desperately wracking my brain to find a career
that will allow me to be a good mom
and spend the necessary time with my kids.
If she wants to be, you know,
she's an ambitious entrepreneur, but also a mother of five
and wants to be able to be a good parent
and an ambitious entrepreneur.
And the dance studio was her business,
or it was just, we don't know.
Yeah, it looks like she was in the dance business.
I'm not sure if she wants to continue in that,
but she was part of the dance studio that closed,
so now she is, she says her confidence is shattered.
So Corinne, I wish I knew more
about what business she specifically wants to be in,
and it says that she's wracking her brain
to find a career, so I don't know if she wants to work,
if she wants to start a business,
or if she just wants to be able to work a job and be a mom.
I'm not exactly sure, but on a very practical level,
if she wants to do work as a parent
and look for opportunity there,
I would suggest checking out flexjobs.com,
which is just a cool website for people
who want to work, but it's also,
I've heard it recommended for parents who work,
who want to be working parents.
That's flexjobs.com, and it comes to mind, too.
I mean, I don't have five kids, so I can't speak to this.
You're the parent in this one, Evan.
I don't want to give parent advice,
but it's really cool when you can start a business
that your kids can somehow be a part of.
I mean, I have a friend who is
in a very successful bakery,
donut shop here in Nashville, Tennessee,
and she has five daughters,
and all of the kids are involved
in the business at some level.
They help in some way, and so it helps
with keeping the family together,
quality time together, even when you're working.
So I'm thinking maybe there's an opportunity
for her to look for ways of doing business
that can include time with your family,
and you see YouTubers, you know?
You're one of them who can sometimes bring your kid on
and do fun videos and things like that,
so I don't know what she'd want to do,
but there's maybe some cool entrepreneurial opportunities
where she could maximize time with her kid
instead of it feeling like it's taking away.
Is that what she says?
She feels like it's taking away from her kids?
Well, that's what she's worried about
is she's really ambitious and career-driven,
but she feels like it's always at the expense of her kids.
Got it.
She's looking for ways where she can be career-driven,
but a good mom.
Got it, but also the business failed
and she doesn't know what she wants to do next.
Is that right?
Yeah, yeah.
Got it.
Okay, so for me, it comes down to having that vision
for yourself, like what do you want to go out and,
is it the dance, is it something else?
What is it that you want to do?
And then making a plan towards it.
Like I would isolate the kids first
from your ambition in your career.
Do you want to be in the dance business?
Do you want to be in something else?
Do you have the skills to do it?
Like if you started a dance studio
and you're wanting to work, I mean, I own a dance studio,
I know what that life is like.
Is that something that, like that's where you want to be
or that was just a fun experiment
and or that was somebody else's business or whatever.
Like set an exciting plan for yourself
of the skills that you want to learn
and the business that you want to be in
and do you have, are you able to do it right now?
Like are you, can you provide enough value
to be a success in that field?
And if not, like if your goal or your dream
is to be a dance studio owner,
can you go work for one, right?
Like again, to get a job,
the reason to get a job is to learn.
And eventually, if your goal is to go out
and be your own boss, that can be great eventually.
But for now you want to, you don't have enough value.
You can't provide, oh, I'm going to die.
The flash, did I make it out?
You made it.
Yeah, I made it out, that was close.
That was close, that was close, that was close.
So yeah, starts with that compelling future for yourself.
What do you want to do?
What do you want to be?
What kind of business do you want to be in?
Do you know?
And if you don't know, it's fine, right?
Like explore, test stuff out.
See you again, what makes you come alive?
Kind of similar advice.
For the kids part, I, you know, there's,
okay, so a couple things.
One, I would put kids time in
just as important as business time in, right?
Like once you create that compelling career future
for yourself, you also want to create a compelling life.
And that obviously involves your kids.
And how much time do you want to spend with them?
Some people need more than others.
And at different times in your life,
your kids will need more than others, right?
Obviously not understanding totally
what your situation's about.
But schedule in your personal stuff.
And this applies to everybody.
If you have kids or not, you know,
you want to spend time with your husband or wife
or girlfriend or brother or whatever,
schedule that in just as importantly as any other meeting.
What tends to happen is we don't schedule
in our personal lives.
And then the business just kind of bleeds into it.
You know, we just keep scheduling stuff
on top of our business.
And that just keeps seeping into our personal lives.
And then you feel like you don't have a personal life.
So blocking it off just like you would
any other important meeting,
blocked it off in your calendar.
I do like to involve my family in the work that I'm doing
to the extent that they want to be involved.
I think it helps.
One, like either just get them involved in the work
so they understand hard work, so they understand,
like you could teach them life lessons
while they're also adding value to what you're doing.
I don't know how old your kids are,
but still you could, you know, Hayden is seven.
He's getting involved in the videos that I make.
So you can do it, you can involve them.
If not, even just explain what you're doing.
So for me, you know, telling Nina about my work
and what's going on and any challenges I'm facing,
that brings us closer together.
Even if she can't offer advice,
even if she doesn't know what to say,
even if she can't give us wisdom,
give me wisdom to help,
just involving her brings us closer together
and makes her feel more connected to what I'm doing
and just makes her feel better.
And so can you involve the kids in that way too?
Can you give them, can you teach them life lessons
through what's going on in your work?
And also can you get them involved
in the actual work somehow?
I think you don't always have to keep everything
super separate and you got to find that balance
that works for you, but starts with having
that compelling future for your career
and then tie that into a compelling future for your life
of what you want to do and how much time
you want to spend in various places.
And then creating a schedule that supports it,
that allows you to do the things that you want to do.
Okay.
Great.
It's getting, it's getting, do you want another one?
Yeah, no, it's getting, it's getting,
it's getting testy here.
We've got, there's a lot of fights happening
because it's close to the end of the game here.
So I'll do my best to balance, but yeah, yeah,
we got, let's do it.
Let's do one more.
All right.
Next question comes from Kamer.
I think I'm sorry, Kamer, if I'm saying that wrong.
He's saying, I'm doing a business school
related to education.
I want from now to have many branches.
How can I act for my branches?
And unfortunately, I don't know,
maybe I need to move on to the next question
because I don't know what he means by,
he's in business school related to education.
I want now to have many branches.
So maybe he wants to be,
if he's in another country, I'm not sure,
do they refer to schools as different,
you know, having different branches and education?
Does anybody know?
I don't know if that's,
should I move on to the next question?
I don't know if that is enough information for you to answer.
So maybe how we approach this is,
and this may not be the problem,
so when we write back to him and say,
hey, here's our answer,
you can give us a little more context,
if we helped him or not.
A lot of people when they're doing education
can feel boxed in, can feel like,
you know, as you get higher up in education,
you're being more and more specific
and you get less and less freedom
and that can be frustrating.
I think of my sister who went through that
and actually quit her PhD program
because it was just more and more specific
and more and more frustrating for her.
She wanted to do, wanted to explore more.
So what would you say,
like let's assume that's the problem,
what would you tell them as advice?
Like I'm going to school and I feel boxed in
by the curriculum, I'm not doing what I want to do.
I want to learn more.
Don't box me in.
Right.
Yeah, well I wonder,
I'm looking at the question again
and saying business school related to education too.
Yeah, I would just say that
perhaps one of your advice to a previous question
was just about being curious
and looking into different interests that you have
and yeah, what really just gets you excited,
what really gets you looking forward
to being a part of the educational field
and if you're feeling boxed in in any way,
I think what's really cool about education
is you can innovate even in the context of education.
So I would think about what really gets you excited
and what are some ways that maybe you can bring
that excitement into that field.
I think it's easy to see restrictions.
I think it's easy to, like because my parents are this way
or because my school is set up like this or whatever,
it's easy, I'm going to die.
I'm going to die.
Oh, the flash, save.
That was insane.
Okay, good, I'm alive.
I think it's easy to just accept your circumstances.
I think it's easy to say, hey, well, I'm at school
and this is the limitation and then just get frustrated
where again, this is on you.
You need to create a better life for yourself
and if you want to stay within the program that you're at
and you're frustrated that you're not learning more,
then go out and find another way to learn more.
Schooling is one option.
There's a lot of ways that you can learn
and get the skills that you need to
and whether that's going out
and starting a business on the side,
whether that's taking a part-time job to learn,
whether that's taking a semester off
to explore what you want to do more,
there's a lot of different ways to do it.
You just got to find, you got to find that for yourself
and not just, like we're all, we are all bound by,
we all often feel bound by our limitations
of our environment.
My parents didn't teach me this.
I'm from this country.
Whatever it is that you feel is a limitation for you.
Did I kill him?
Yeah, I killed him.
And it's just, so whatever the context is,
in this case at school, but for the other people watching,
it might be something else.
You place these limits where you got to unshackle that
and if you're feeling like you want to learn something else,
again, it doesn't have to take a massive,
oh, somebody quit the game.
We're playing four against five now.
It doesn't have to take a massive shift yet.
Just start small.
Like, what are you upset that you're not learning?
Where do you want to learn more?
What is it?
Like, what skill?
So you're learning business, great.
What do you want to learn that's different,
that you're frustrated with,
that you don't have enough knowledge in?
What is that thing?
Yeah, I got another kill.
And then just go find a small way to get started and do it.
Just find a small way and do it.
It doesn't have to be, quit everything.
My life is terrible, everything sucks.
Just find a small way to get started and go do it.
And if that makes you come alive,
like you might discover,
like maybe you want to be an actor as well.
I'm just throwing something out there.
Okay.
Instead of just thinking about being an actor,
go out and try, take a class, learn, try to get better.
And you may go to acting classes and then realize,
you know what, acting sucks.
I don't want to be an actor.
Wow.
Oh, my guy just came back.
Let's hope he joins the game.
And you would have never known that
unless you actually took some kind of action towards it,
where a lot of people have these dreams
of something they want to do.
Like a previous caller,
or caller, I want to say caller, question.
Previous caller.
It would be cool to have calls.
Yeah.
Previous question.
We won.
Who started off in something and then wasn't happy, right?
Like this business isn't for me
or I forget what the exact context was,
but like you start on something
that may not always work out.
It may not be for you.
And then the thing is a switch.
So if you're unhappy with your current situation,
find a small way to start switching.
It doesn't have to be a drastic change.
It doesn't have to be something huge
and innovative and different.
Just find a small way to get started
and see if it makes you feel alive.
If I love this, if I like can't wait to get up
and play League of Legends and talk to Rishy,
and that's, I'm going to do, I'm going to say Kiki.
If that's like all I can wait to do,
then like if I get such a high from doing this,
then I might kill my YouTube channel
and just go all in on this.
Which may upset some people.
But it's being true to me, right?
So find a small way to get started.
This is a small test for me.
One of many small tests that I do constantly on my channel
that maybe you guys see, maybe you don't.
This is a more public one.
And I look for something that makes me come alive.
When I find that, then I invest more into it.
So after all of my team complaining and everything,
I ended up with eight kills, one death, eight assists,
and I got the best score in the game.
So that can't be that bad.
Can't be that bad.
That's a pretty solid start.
That's a great game to be on the first game
of our stream back online.
Cool, well thank you guys for the questions.
Yeah?
Does this mean you're not going to do
the same live stream with Pokemon Go?
I am not into Pokemon Go.
Nina is though.
You could join Nina for Pokemon Go live streaming.
I'm not into Pokemon Go.
But cool, thank you guys for the questions.
Hopefully it helped.
Thank you guys for joining live.
Thank you Rishy for joining in.
We're going to link up her channel in the description
so you can go check out what she's up to
on YouTube as well.
And everybody check out Evan's new book launch.
Tell them really quickly before we leave
if they haven't heard already.
Yeah, you can go to,
we'll just check out the description of the video.
There you go.
The book is about finding your one word.
Actually it would be super helpful
for the people who are having a lot of issues.
We should have maybe read that up earlier on.
But, yeah, yeah, check it out.
Really appreciate the support.
And that's it.
Have an amazing week.
We will do this again and continue to believe
or whatever your one word is.
And we'll see you soon.
Bye guys.